and finally it's time for another
edition of explaining jokes to idiots
the segment where we explain two idiots
jokes they missed because they're idiots
and tonight I'd like to examine the
reaction to Amy Schumer's new film I
feel pretty which the professionally
offended have decided that even though
it's a movie by women filmmakers
presenting a probe woman message it does
it the wrong way
Amy helped wrong even though she really
just remade the Nutty Professor where
someone not thin and not cool magically
sees themselves as better looking and
gains confidence except when Eddie
Murphy did it he didn't have the purity
police up his ass
[Music]
The Hollywood Reporter wrote an article
dissecting I feel pretty and it's
questionable message of empowerment
Rolling Stone called its fat shaming the
independent reviewing the trailer cuz
why wait for the actual movie when you
can start your hating two months early
wrote that I feel pretty seems so
offensive it's frankly exhausting
exhausted by a movie trailer I think
we've reached peak snowflake
the LA Times asked wouldn't a bolder
more progressive version of the story
have cast a woman of color Oh for
Christ's sake can it just be funny can't
we just sit in a movie theater unclench
our [ __ ] for two hours and laugh at
what it is instead of dissecting it for
what it is not movie reviews they're not
even reviews anymore
they're just outcome you made the movie
you made I'm not the one I would have
made
if I had talent which I don't some
reviews noted that casting Amy as the
ugly fat person undermined truly ugly
fat people bad Amy not fat enough others
asked why her self-esteem had to be
linked to her physical appearance and
yes why wasn't the role given to a woman
of color I don't know maybe because they
thought since it's an Amy Schumer movie
they ought to have Amy Schumer in it he
wound up by the way apologizing for
appearing in her own movie on the view
she said I recognize that I'm Caucasian
I would love of this movie were starring
a woman of color who's had it way harder
than me yeah because all goofy comedy
should also address the black experience
like that one where Jennifer Garner grew
up overnight remember that one 13 going
on 30 years of slave
[Applause]
life is too complicated to reduce
everything to real problems on one side
and white problems on the other you can
be white and still have a life where you
pray for death just ask Melania well but
being white is hardly the only thing Amy
did wrong the New York Post says the
film is tone-deaf forecasting a straight
white able-bodied blonde and the
independent concurs noting the film was
flawed because amy was still blonde
able-bodied and well dressed with all
the trappings of Western beauty
standards yes she's a traitor to
feminists and because she wears clothes
has all her limbs and is hotter than
predator comedian Sophie Hagen also
noted Amy's able-bodied miss what is it
with this adding the cheese femme and
yes thin she is society's beauty ideal
no she's precisely not that's her act
you idiots but you know
you know who is society's beauty ideal
this one the one feminists love more
than life itself a 6-foot supermodel in
hot pants newsflash people just like the
physically attractive better sorry the
taller candidate usually wins the
election studies show the better-looking
person other things being equal usually
gets the job even babies prefer to look
at attractive faces oh where do you see
the blog I'm gonna post tomorrow tearing
them a new [ __ ] babies
models are tall and thin because that's
what sells clothes the answer isn't to
insist that everyone in society love you
exactly the way you are it's to learn to
tell the ones who don't that you don't
need them which is exactly what ami
learns in the movie just the way at the
end of The Wizard of Oz Dorothy realizes
she didn't have to go on that big acid
trip to appreciate what she had at home
when will liberals learn that barking it
nothing makes people not want to listen
when you actually have something to say
it's no talent to endlessly [ __ ] about
what isn't there although I'll tell you
black panther should have had more
Puerto Ricans